Jake:哦
Jake: Oh.
Jake:我靠这已经是汤了
Jake: Oh my, this has turned into soup.
Jake:这冰淇淋这麦旋风
Jake: This ice cream, this McFlurry.
Jake:饮这汤呢有用吗
Jake: Does drinking this soup even help?
其他人:有有有
Others: Yes, yes, yes.
Jake:那就动一下放到下面就行
Jake: Just move it down below.
Alice:你放下边
Alice: Put it below.
Jake:放下面好嘞
Jake: Put it below, okay.
Jake:我操哈哈
Jake: Oh crap, haha.
Jake:哈呃自取灭亡
Jake: Haha, self-destruction.
Shure: 高蛋白
Shure: High protein.
Jake:给给您吃哈哈
Jake: Here, you eat it, haha.
Shure: 这是油还是啊
Shure: Is this oil or what?
Shure: 哇谁这么奢侈
Shure: Wow, who is so extravagant?
Shure: 点的安格斯候牛榜
Shure: Ordered the Angus beef burger.
Jake:我靠放放放这我靠
Jake: Oh my, put it, put it, oh my.
Alice:之前说吃安格斯混油果的都是渣女
Alice: They say girls who eat Angus mixed fruit are trashy.
Alice:是个捞女
Alice: They're gold diggers.
Alice:是吗
Alice: Really?
Alice:是吗是
Alice: Really, really?
Alice:是有那个梗是吧对对对
Alice: There's that joke, right? Yes, yes.
Shure: 不能吃便宜的
Shure: Can't eat cheap ones.
Shure: 烤这么贵的
Shure: Roast such expensive ones.
Jake:盲盒盲盒盲盒
Jake: Mystery box, mystery box, mystery box.
Jake:还有谁没挑吗
Jake: Anyone else not picked?
Lucia:乱拆
Lucia: Randomly open.
Jake:谁有派吗
Jake: Who has a pie?
Jake:派是怎么点的
Jake: How do you order a pie?
Alice:派是我点我点了两个派
Alice: I ordered the pies, I ordered two pies.
Jake:好嘞
Jake: Okay.
Lucia:是这个吗
Lucia: Is it this one?
Jake:好
Jake: Okay
Jake:薯条薯条都是谁
Jake: Whose fries are these?
Jake:薯条就分着吃吧
Jake: Let's just share the fries
Jake:但是没有地方放呢要不然
Jake: But there's no place to put them, how about...
Jake:怎么找不到呵呵呵呃OK OK
Jake: Why can't I find it? Haha, umm, OK OK
Lucia:嗯
Lucia: Hmm
Jake:哎呀呀呀好损失了8根
Jake: Oh no, we lost 8 fries
Lucia:对不起对不起
Lucia: Sorry, sorry
Jake:麦当劳汉堡
Jake: McDonald's burger
Jake:麦当劳薯条
Jake: McDonald's fries
Jake:薯条这叫什么呀这叫
Jake: What's this called? This is called...
Jake:薯条自由是吗
Jake: Fry freedom, right?
Lucia:才给这么点番茄酱
Lucia: Only this much ketchup?
Jake:太少了
Jake: It's too little
小薇 :我们需要走路了吗
Tasha: Do we need to walk?
Jake:呃还还有很多
Jake: Uh, there's still a lot
Jake:也没有很多了
Jake: Actually, not that much
Jake:还有几个
Jake: Just a few left
Lucia:我想你是直接挤在上面的
Lucia: I thought you squeezed it directly on top
Lucia:我以为是挤在旁边然后站的那种
Lucia: I thought you squeezed it on the side and then stood it up
Jake:哦OK那也行
Jake: Oh, OK, that works too
Lucia:没事都行
Lucia: It's fine, whatever
Lucia:无所谓了
Lucia: Doesn't matter
Jake:好好挤旁边合理
Jake: Okay, squeezing it on the side is reasonable
其他人:这个能吃了吗
Others: Can we eat this?
Jake:这个不可以吃
Jake: No, you can't eat this
Tasha:陈老师嗯
Tasha: Mr. Chen, hmm
Tasha:你能把桌子收一下
Tasha: Can you clear the table?
Tasha:把外面的所有盘都拿进来
Tasha: Bring all the plates from outside
Tasha:我们摆一下嘛
Tasha: Let's set it up
Jake:好
Jake: Okay
还有一盒薯条
Still have another box of fries
Lucia:居然这么多薯条
Lucia: So many fries
Alice:盐我都放在那了
Alice: I put all the salt there
Alice:哈
Alice: Ha
其他人:卧槽
Others: Whoa
Alice:哈
Alice: Ha
Alice:太搞笑了
Alice: That's so funny
Shure: 我要小开个会了家人们
Shure: I need to have a little meeting with the family
Jake:还有3个宝是谁的
Jake: Who owns these 3 treasures?
Jake:有一个是我的
Jake: One of them is mine.
Jake:可能吧
Jake: Maybe.
Jake:这个可以开
Jake: This can be opened.
Shure: 要开个会
Shure: We need to have a meeting.
Jake:你关了吧
Jake: Turn it off.
Jake:你关了吧你开会
Jake: Turn it off and have the meeting.
Jake:你再开嘛
Jake: You can turn it on again later.
其他人:我靠我草
Other: Oh my god, oh crap.
其他人:感动死我了
Other: I'm so touched.
Jake:我嗨了啊
Jake: I'm so excited.
Jake:我嗨了呃开会
Jake: I'm so excited, let's have the meeting.
其他人:呃开会
Other: Uh, let's have the meeting.
其他人:但是我们
Other: But we...
Jake:哦
Jake: Oh.
其他人:他刚让我妈拆开一个bug
Other: He just asked my mom to open a bug.
其他人:他要他来一个我写bug
Other: He wants him to write a bug.
其他人:哎怎么这么多厚图包
Other: Why are there so many thick packs?
Jake:盲盒盲盒
Jake: Blind box, blind box.
其他人:你想想你当时点的那个
Other: Think about what you ordered back then.
其他人:我点的我点的应该是培根
Other: What I ordered should have been bacon.
其他人:啊培根
Other: Ah, bacon.
其他人:那可能我给你吃了
Other: Maybe I gave it to you.
其他人:但我记得我点的培根
Other: But I remember I ordered bacon.
其他人:怎么还开火了
Other: Why is the stove on?
Jake:什么牛排
Jake: What steak?
其他人:牛排是不是刘太监的
Other: Is the steak Choiszt's?
其他人:哦我想起来我菜的菜
Other: Oh, I remember my dish.
Jake:他怎么发成这样了
Jake: Why is he sending it like this?
其他人:不好意思
Other: Sorry.
Alice:你把桌子收拾了吗
Alice: Did you clean the table?
Jake:我我我
Jake: I, I, I...
Jake:我看看怎么收拾
Jake: I'll see how to clean it.
Jake:这个怎么收掉
Jake: How do I clean this?
Tasha:这还有一块
Tasha: There's still a piece here.
Tasha:谁来认领一下
Tasha: Someone claim it.
Jake:认领一下放牛排里吧
Jake: Claim it and put it with the steak.
Jake:嗯
Jake: Hmm.
Tasha:之前我在上海吃学生那傻屌地方
Tasha: I used to eat at that dumb student place in Shanghai.
Tasha:不是只有那个中国总部吗
Tasha: Isn't it the China headquarters?
Tasha:天天去吃麦当劳
Tasha: I ate McDonald's every day.
Tasha:有的那年给我吃吐了
Tasha: One year, it made me puke.
Tasha:一点都不想吃
Tasha: I don't want to eat it at all.
Jake:是这种吗
Jake: Is it this kind?
Jake:是一样的
Jake: It's the same.
Jake:这个丢掉哈
Jake: Throw this away.
Jake:丢掉吗丢掉
Jake: Throw it away, just throw it away.
Tasha:丢掉
Tasha: Throw it away.
Alice:你刚切了芒果
Alice: You just cut the mango.
Alice:呃菠萝是芒果
Alice: Uh, pineapple is mango.
Jake:这有差别吗
Jake: Is there a difference?
Jake:麦当劳汉堡
Jake: McDonald's burgers.
其他人:今天中午吃汉堡晚上吃麦当劳
Others: We had burgers for lunch and McDonald's for dinner.
Jake:有垃圾袋
Jake: There's a trash bag.
Jake:这边有垃圾袋
Jake: There's a trash bag here.
Lucia:这是我的还没吃完
Lucia: This is mine, I haven't finished eating.
Alice:蛋清
Alice: Egg white.
Jake:呢
Jake: Yeah?
Jake:大伙了大伙了
Jake: Everyone, everyone.
Alice:蛋黄打打进那里面了
Alice: The egg yolk goes in there.
Jake:蘸个酱
Jake: Dip it in sauce.
Jake:哦这还有个
Jake: Oh, there's another one here.
Jake:我靠开不了啊
Jake: Damn, I can't open it.
Alice:你在欣赏自己的作品吗
Alice: Are you admiring your work?
Alice:无纺一分熟也是熟
Alice: Medium rare is still cooked.
Jake:哈
Jake: Huh?
Jake:我把酱开了
Jake: I opened the sauce.
Jake:鸡块没了
Jake: No more chicken nuggets.
Jake:哈哈是吧
Jake: Haha, right?
Jake:还有两只
Jake: There are two more.
Jake:在哪啊瞎不好意思
Jake: Where are they? Oh, sorry.
Lucia:这个也可以
Lucia: This one is okay too.
其他人:吃麦当劳为什么不需要蘸酱
Others: Why don't you need sauce for McDonald's?
Jake:为什么呢不知道
Jake: Why? I don't know.
Katrina: 你是哪人啊
Katrina: Where are you from?
Katrina: 我当时还以为你是北京人哈
Katrina: I thought you were from Beijing.
其他人:我说话没有精盐味
Others: I don't speak with a Beijing accent.
其他人:味道不纯
Others: The flavor isn't pure.
其他人:但
Others: But
其他人:我确实很好的融入了北京的社会环境
Others: I've integrated well into Beijing's social environment.
Jake:怎么热爱挤地
Jake: How do you love squeezing the subway?
Jake:铁哼哼哼
Jake: Iron hum hum hum
其他人:不热爱挤地铁
Others: Not loving the crowded subway
Jake:其他人:
Jake: Others:
其他人:真的
Others: Really
其他人:我在北京上海实习之后我喜欢上海
Others: After interning in Beijing and Shanghai, I prefer Shanghai
其他人:最重要一点就是
Others: The most important point is
其他人:因为我在上海打车便宜
Others: Because taking taxis in Shanghai is cheaper
其他人:因为上海最省
Others: Because it's more economical in Shanghai
Jake:啊真的
Jake: Oh really
Alice:发短信不回
Alice: Not replying to texts
Jake:不会吧
Jake: No way
Jake:拍摆
Jake: Pose
Jake:拍摆拍摆
Jake: Pose, pose
Alice:用那个湿纸巾擦一擦厨房
Alice: Use that wet wipe to clean the kitchen
Lucia:厨房也没有洗洁精吧
Lucia: The kitchen doesn't have dishwashing liquid, right?
Alice:你要摆一下吗
Alice: Do you want to pose?
Lucia:不能只能用那那个那种纸吗
Lucia: Can't we only use those kinds of wipes?
Jake:哼
Jake: Huh
Lucia:湿湿纸巾
Lucia: Wet wipes
Jake:撒盐啊或者餐巾纸加水也行
Jake: Sprinkle salt or use napkins with water
Alice:或者餐巾纸加水也行
Alice: Or use napkins with water
Jake:撒一个撒一个
Jake: Sprinkle some, sprinkle some
Jake:撒了吧你
Jake: Go ahead, sprinkle
Jake:还没撒呢
Jake: Haven't sprinkled yet
其他人:有点小浪费
Others: A bit wasteful
其他人:撒那个吧
Others: Sprinkle that one
其他人:这个有点太咸了
Others: This one's a bit too salty
其他人:撒这个再撒这个
Others: Sprinkle this one, then sprinkle this one
Alice:撒过了
Alice: Already sprinkled
Jake:打他是不是从那边外面拍
Jake: Should I shoot from outside?
Jake:从外面拍从外面拍
Jake: Shoot from outside, shoot from outside
其他人:这个这个直接装盘吗
Others: Should we directly plate this?
Jake:哈哈哈
Jake: Hahaha
Jake:8个机位
Jake: 8 camera angles
Jake:多少有点猥琐
Jake: It's a bit sneaky
Jake:美美
Jake: Beautiful
Lucia:应该是吧
Lucia: I think so
其他人:感觉动作不太对
Others: The movement feels off
Jake:挺对了差不多
Jake: Pretty close, almost there
Jake:哈哈哈这个
Jake: Hahaha this
Jake:太矮了你你你越这样对吧
Jake: Too short, the higher you lift it, right?
Jake:这抬得越高越好
Jake: The higher you lift it, the better.
Alice:哭吗
Alice: Should I cry?
Alice:那我搁那了
Alice: Okay, I'll leave it there.
Jake:哼干热泡面然后开始上菜
Jake: Hmph, eat hot dry noodles and then start serving dishes.
其他人:真的刘帅
Others: Really, Choiszt.
其他人:我要是女生我嫁
Others: If I were a girl, I'd marry him.
Jake:呵呵呵呵呵呵呵呵呵呵呵呵可惜
Jake: Hahahahahahahaha, what a pity.
Jake:可惜啊
Jake: What a pity.
Jake:嗯
Jake: Hmm.
Jake:嗯好吃
Jake: Hmm, delicious.
Jake:确实可以确实可以
Jake: It's really good, really good.
Jake:确实很可以
Jake: It's really very good.
其他人:凑巧做做成了一次
Others: Just happened to make it once.
其他人:有没有非常的谦虚啊
Others: Isn't he very humble?
其他人:如果我是一个女生
Others: If I were a girl,
其他人:我就非常喜欢谦虚的男人
Others: I would really like humble men.
其他人:哈哈哈哈
Others: Hahaha.
Katrina: 你的掩盖不了你爱上他的事实
Katrina: You can't hide the fact that you love him.
其他人:我自从有一次点了麦当劳的牛奶
Others: Ever since I ordered McDonald's milk once,
其他人:麦当劳的牛奶非常的牛
Others: McDonald's milk is really something.
Jake:嗯好喝
Jake: Hmm, tasty.
Lucia:这渣怎么掉不出来啊
Lucia: Why won't these crumbs come out?
Jake:渣木头渣
Jake: Crumbs, wooden crumbs.
Lucia:没有就是拿拿厨房纸擦一下的话
Lucia: No, just wipe it with a kitchen towel.
Lucia:厨房纸会掉
Lucia: The kitchen towel will shed.
Lucia:一些小渣
Lucia: Some small crumbs.
Jake:哦
Jake: Oh.
Lucia:这里面也铺那个啥算了
Lucia: Just put some parchment paper inside, forget it.
Lucia:也铺那个油纸算
Lucia: Just put some parchment paper.
其他人:我看啥时候跟女朋友分手
Others: I'll see when to break up with my girlfriend.
Jake:哈哈哈哈
Jake: Hahahaha.
其他人:哈哈哈时间管理大师
Others: Hahaha, time management master.
Jake:对
Jake: Yes.
Alice:给薇薇留一个
Alice: Save one for Tasha.
Alice:给薇薇
Alice: For Tasha.
Jake:今天还要做几道几道甜点
Jake: How many desserts are we making today?
Jake:快完成的3道
Jake: Almost done with three.
Jake:会优秀员工
Jake: Will be an outstanding employee.
Jake:这就是一路在记录
Jake: This is all being recorded.
Jake:哎人呢
Jake: Hey, where is everyone?
Jake:开会啊
Jake: Meeting time, huh?
Jake:嗯
Jake: Hmm.
Lucia:山药还挺好吃
Lucia: The yam is pretty tasty.
Jake:你们明天都呃决定了
Jake: Have you all decided for tomorrow?
Jake:几个人啊
Jake: How many people?
Jake:一个
Jake: One.
Jake:几个
Jake: How many?
Jake:哼哼哼你有一堆啊
Jake: Haha, you have a bunch, huh?
其他人:嗯对
Others: Yeah, right.
其他人:这环球拉人魂未取消啊
Others: This global soul-grabbing hasn't been canceled.
Jake:走现在走
Jake: Let's go, let's go now.
Jake:呵呵呵没有没有没有取消了
Jake: Haha, no, it hasn't been canceled.
Jake:怕怕外边的人挺麻烦
Jake: I'm afraid the people outside are quite troublesome.
Jake:嗯
Jake: Hmm.
Jake:卖门票对
Jake: Selling tickets, right.
Jake:看看能不能把这几天本给毁了
Jake: Let's see if we can ruin the book these days.
其他人:我跟你讲
Others: Let me tell you.
其他人:你去海淀黄庄门口
Others: You go to Haidian Huangzhuang.
Jake:海淀黄庄
Jake: Haidian Huangzhuang.
Jake:我靠我靠
Jake: Oh my god, oh my god.
Jake:不是你组个名字就一天
Jake: No, you just make a name for one day.
Jake:开玩笑呵呵可以
Jake: Just kidding, haha, okay.
Jake:嗯
Jake: Hmm.
Jake:不是不是
Jake: No, no.
Jake:才才数一天吗
Jake: Just counting one day?
其他人:你的孩子
Others: Your child
其他人:将来有可能会出现在我们的论文里面
Others: might appear in our papers in the future.
其他人:我们是做AI的
Others: We are doing AI.
其他人:你知道我们女子今年开始的高峰赛道
Others: You know the peak track for women started this year.
其他人::你不想想你的孩子不能输在起跑
Others: Don’t you think your child can’t lose at the starting line?
其他人:孩子升到初中正好结婚
Others: When the child goes to middle school, just in time for marriage.
其他人:是开初中赛道了
Others: It's the middle school track.
其他人:对
Others: Right.
其他人:海淀皇上那味可抽
Others: The taste of Haidian Emperor can be drawn.
其他人:我操我知道海淀皇上初中
Others: Damn, I know Haidian Emperor Middle School.
其他人:哈哈哈
Others: Hahaha.
其他人:那你不是在海淀皇上捡生捡死吗
Others: Aren’t you picking life and death at Haidian Emperor?
其他人:我感觉
Others: I feel
其他人:我感觉你应该不属于那种极度激娃的
Others: I feel like you shouldn't be that kind of extreme parent.
其他人:真的吗
Others: Really?
其他人:还有我身边的人都是小学
Others: Also, the people around me are all in elementary school.
其他人:初中什么上课的班的人
Others: Middle school students or something.
其他人:都是都带海带王装啊
Others: They all wear seaweed king suits.
其他人:都带海带王装吗
Others: Do they all wear seaweed king suits?
其他人:对这都是什么人大富人我
Others: Yeah, what kind of rich people are these?
其他人:感觉我跟他们人大富人接触一下
Others: I feel like I'm mingling with rich people.
其他人:他们人大富人确实挺厉害的
Others: These rich people are really impressive.
其他人:哎你
Others: Hey, you.
其他人:你身上有有人大富人吗
Others: Do you have any rich people around you?
Lucia:这我自己
Lucia: It's just me.
Alice:我可以看一下吗
Alice: Can I take a look?
Jake:恭喜进入
Alice:这是狐狸吗对
Alice: Is this a fox? Yes.
Alice:哈哈哈谢谢好可爱
Alice: Hahaha, thank you, it's so cute.
其他人:是不
Others: Isn't it?
其他人:是
Others: Yes.
其他人:对
Others: Right.
其他人:非常的非常的夸张
Others: It's really, really exaggerated.
其他人:这
Others: This.
其他人:我之前是参加此期实践的时候认识的
Others: I met them during a practice session before.
其他人:当时我也能打
Others: At that time, I could also play.
其他人:所以名县人越多越好
Others: So, the more famous people, the better.
其他人:你
Others: You.
其他人: 女朋友啊
Others: Girlfriend?
Jake:你开两辆车过来
Jake: You drive two cars over here.
其他人:又堵车没有没有没有
Others: Traffic jam again, no, no, no.
Jake:这可以别人也开吗
Jake: Can others drive too?
其他人:我想想我今天去海边王岛
Others: I'm thinking of going to King Island Beach today.
其他人:每次带的地方
Others: The place I always go.
其他人:下一站都会去新中关购物中
Others: The next stop will be Xinzhongguan Shopping Center.
其他人:心或者林展购物中心玩耍
Others: Or Linzhan Shopping Center to hang out.
其他人:丝毫没有
Others: No.
其他人:体会到海边王岛的危险的地方
Others: I didn't feel any danger at King Island Beach.
其他人:明天几点
Others: What time tomorrow?
Jake:下午两点半两点半
Jake: 2:30 in the afternoon, 2:30.
其他人:两点半
Others: 2:30.
Jake:你刚才说有这个伊罗币
Jake: You just mentioned there's this Eros coin.
Jake:过来踩伊罗币
Jake: Come over and step on Eros coin.
其他人:其实说的很好玩
Others: Actually, it sounds fun.
Jake:嗯行
Jake: Hmm, okay.
Jake:白吃白喝
Jake: Free food and drink.
Jake:就是白吃白喝
Jake: Just free food and drink.
其他人:免费接送加白吃白喝嗯
Others: Free transport plus free food and drink, yeah.
Jake:什么东西
Jake: What's that?
Alice:恋爱负责接送的吗
Alice: Is love responsible for the pickup?
Alice:比较难吧
Alice: It's quite difficult, right?
Jake:嗯对他们北欧的可以方便
Jake: Yeah, it's convenient for those in Northern Europe.
Jake:海淀那边的方便一点
Jake: It's more convenient for those in Haidian.
Alice:这离地铁站远吗 1号线
Alice: Is it far from the subway station, Line 1?
其他人:不远
Others: Not far.
Jake:我们可以到地铁站里面没问题
Jake: We can get to the subway station, no problem.
其他人:对可以给他搞一个
Others: Yeah, we can arrange that.
其他人:地铁站到那个接驳车
Others: A shuttle bus from the subway station.
其他人:大概半个小时一趟
Others: About every half an hour.
其他人:还是来过一次哈哈哈
Others: Still, come over once, haha.
Jake:那就开始啊那不行
Jake: Then let's start, okay? No, that's not okay.
其他人:哦他可以不按照那个路
Others: Oh, he doesn't have to follow that route.
其他人:所以我不是借拨车吗
Others: So I'm not borrowing a shuttle bus?
Jake:对呵呵呵呵
Jake: Yeah, hahaha.
Jake:你你再租个车
Jake: You can rent another car.
Jake:然后给死亡开
Jake: And then drive it to death.
Lucia:是要用刀切一下呀
Lucia: Should we cut it with a knife?
Jake:哎这个蛋挞怎么是个饼啊
Jake: Hey, why is this egg tart a pancake?
Jake:一眼看到了
Jake: I saw it at a glance.
Jake:很好看的一个
Jake: It looks really nice.
Jake:哇
Jake: Wow.
Alice:花刀呢我以为你拿了
Alice: Where's the decorative knife? I thought you took it.
Jake:麦
Jake: Mike.
Lucia:我来吃
Lucia: I'll eat it.
Lucia:刮刀在哪
Lucia: Where's the scraper?
Lucia:呃不是这个是一个塑料的对吧
Lucia: Uh, no, this one is plastic, right?
Jake:确实
Jake: Indeed.
Lucia:塑料的
Lucia: Plastic.
Jake:麦当劳汉堡
Jake: McDonald's burger.
Lucia:谢谢
Lucia: Thanks.
Jake:麦当劳
Jake: McDonald's.
Jake:嗯
Jake: Hmm.
Jake:麦当劳汉堡
Jake: McDonald's burger.
Jake:嗯嗯
Jake: Uh-huh.
Jake:我们高级东西可多
Jake: We have a lot of fancy stuff.
Jake:很多我们不理解的东西
Jake: A lot of things we don't understand.
Jake:抹哪啊
Jake: Where to apply it?
Jake:抹抹头上
Jake: Apply it on the head.
Jake:一掌拍下去
Jake: Slap it down with one hand.
Jake:我每天都这样吃对
Jake: I eat like this every day, right?
Alice:我们我每天都这样吃
Alice: We eat like this every day.
Alice:哈哈哈哈
Alice: Hahaha.
Jake:每天一公斤糖
Jake: One kilogram of sugar every day.
Jake:这几天伙食太好了这个
Jake: The food has been so good these days.
其他人:这奶油是吧
Others: Is this cream?
Jake:对就是奶油
Jake: Yes, it's cream.
Jake:剪下来了吗
Jake: Did you cut it?
其他人:嗯不甜
Others: Hmm, not sweet.
Lucia:没有
Lucia: No.
Jake:没有呵呵呵呵
Jake: No, hahaha.
其他人:最高评价
Others: Highest rating.
Jake:蛋挞加奶油
Jake: Egg tart with cream.
其他人:有点像那个东西
Others: It looks like that thing.
Jake:什么东西
Jake: What thing?
Jake:细数细数啊啊
Jake: Count it, count it, ah ah.
其他人:在喷点上面喷点巧克力
Others: Spray some chocolate on top.
小薇 :是的会喷的
Tasha: Yes, it will spray.
Tasha:喷的
Tasha: It sprays.
其他人:或者提拉米苏就更像
Others: Or it looks more like tiramisu.
Alice:拿个刮刀能把它抹平吗
Alice: Can you smooth it out with a spatula?
Alice:我来吧
Alice: Let me do it.
其他人:你这个是专门设计的图案啊
Others: Is this a specially designed pattern?
Alice:小刮刀吗
Alice: A small spatula?
其他人:还没还要抹平呢
Others: Not yet, it still needs to be smoothed out.
其他人:要抹平未完工
Others: It needs to be smoothed out, not finished yet.
其他人:这个给我吧
Others: Give it to me.
其他人:既然都已经坏了
Others: Since it's already ruined.
Jake:他们都是一样的吗
Jake: Are they all the same?
Jake:还是说就这几个
Jake: Or just these few?
Alice:有小的没找到小的
Alice: There's a small one, but I couldn't find it.
Lucia:小的那个刚刚没找着有吗
Lucia: Couldn't find the small one just now, is there one?
其他人:这么刮大了
Others: It's getting so big.
其他人:你这个都
Others: You've done all this.
Jake:哈哈会动吗
Jake: Haha, can it move?
Tasha:会动没关系
Tasha: It's fine if it moves.
Jake:看你水平了
Jake: Let's see your skills.
其他人:你自己在家做蛋挞吃也是加这么多料
Others: When you make egg tarts at home, do you add this much stuff?
Alice:呃没有了
Alice: Uh, not really.
Jake:拿去卖了
Jake: Sell it then.
Tasha:经费足呵呵呵
Tasha: We've got enough budget, haha.
Jake:这么回事
Jake: What's the deal?
其他人:可以录的吗
Others: Can we record this?
Jake:可以可以
Jake: Sure, sure.
Lucia:呃我觉得这个也可以用
Lucia: Uh, I think this can be used too.
Lucia:微微那个这种小刀也可以吧
Lucia: Tasha, this small knife can be used too, right?
Tasha:他他抹了
Tasha: He's already spread it.
Tasha:OK了没关系了
Tasha: It's fine now.
Jake:就这样吧
Jake: Let's go with this.
Lucia:啊那就那就用这个吧
Lucia: Ah, then let's use this.
Lucia:就用这个
Lucia: We'll use this.
Lucia:大的也行
Lucia: The big one works too.
其他人:直接给他铺平就行
Others: Just spread it out evenly.
其他人:但是水果还没加
Others: But the fruits aren't added yet.
其他人:这为什么这么稀呀
Others: Why is it so watery?
Alice:这还稀啊
Alice: This is watery?
Alice:这个哦这这边还有一个
Alice: This one, oh, there's another one over here.
Alice:太会抹了
Alice: You're really good at spreading.
Alice:你不会偷偷学过吧
Alice: Did you secretly practice?
其他人:啊这还会抹
Others: Ah, you can spread too.
其他人:这不都瞎抹的
Others: This is just randomly spread.
Alice:这个应该快没那个存储了
Alice: This storage is almost full.
Jake:看一下呃
Jake: Check it out, uh...
Jake:就等没清楚就停吧
Jake: Just stop when it's not clear.
Jake:就是咱也还有
Jake: We still have...
Jake:还有还有半个小时
Jake: We still have half an hour.
Jake:没有就是这一轮33
Jake: No, this round is 33.
Alice:33
Alice: 33.
Jake:对啊半个小时
Jake: Yeah, half an hour.
Jake:一个小时40分钟吧
Jake: An hour and 40 minutes.
Alice:甜品师傅
Alice: Dessert chef.
其他人:刮刮腻子师傅
Others: Putty master.
Jake:嗯把这换成叉子
Jake: Hmm, let's switch this to a fork.
Jake:我觉得也挺好
Jake: I think that's good too.
Lucia:那个盘现在要铺上这个
Lucia: Now, put this on the plate.
Lucia:这个油纸吗
Lucia: Is this parchment paper?
Alice:我觉得不铺好看
Alice: I think it looks better without it.
Jake:那就不铺
Jake: Then let's not use it.
Lucia:他蛋挞底下是有那个啊
Lucia: There's something under the egg tart, you know.
Alice:没有没有
Alice: No, no there isn't.
Jake:嗯那还是扑一下吧
Jake: Hmm, let's just use it.
Lucia:因为那个刚拆开
Lucia: Because it was just opened.
Lucia:就我刚用纸擦的时候它稍
Lucia: When I wiped it with paper, it slightly...
Lucia:微有点掉色其实因为它是个新的嘛
Lucia: ...discolored a bit because it's new.
Jake:哦
Jake: Oh.
Lucia:所以要不然咱们安全起见
Lucia: So, just to be safe.
Jake:那我们稍微扑一扑
Jake: Let's use a bit, just a bit.
Jake:稍微扑一扑
Jake: Just a bit.
Jake:小扑一下
Jake: Just a little.
Lucia:比划比划啊
Lucia: Just to try it out.
其他人:哦我们明天车有多少人我
Others: Oh, how many people will be in the car tomorrow?
Lucia:这个宽度好像还行
Lucia: This width seems fine.
Jake:嗯合适合适的不得了可以
Jake: Yes, it's perfect, very good.
Lucia:可以
Lucia: It's good.
Lucia:那就把它撕齐一点
Lucia: Let's tear it straight.
Lucia:我把这往里拽一拽
Lucia: I'll pull this in.
其他人:他明天不来吗
Others: He's not coming tomorrow?
Jake:来来来来来
Jake: He's coming, he's coming.
Jake:好
Jake: Okay.
Jake:你的车是哪来
Jake: Where's your car from?
其他人:他自己的车
Others: His own car.
其他人:啊
Others: Ah.
Lucia:我
Lucia: I...
Lucia:觉这个长度应该差不多
Lucia: ...think this length should be enough.
Jake:来请坐
Jake: Come, have a seat.
其他人:我有义有吾有义
Others: I have justice, I have justice.
Lucia:咦可恶
Lucia: Ugh, annoying.
Jake:来我来玩
Jake: Let me play.
Lucia:稍微有点歪
Lucia: It's a bit crooked.
Jake:我要玩嗯玩不了
Jake: I want to play. Hmm, I can't play.
Jake:土豆粉
Jake: Potato flour.
Alice:黄豆粉
Alice: Soybean flour.
Jake:黄豆粉是谁
Jake: Who is Huangdoufen?
Lucia:我感觉左边这个没有撕齐
Lucia: I feel like the left side wasn't torn properly.
Lucia:要不再重撕一下
Lucia: Should we tear it again?
Jake:哦
Jake: Oh.
Jake:熟黄豆粉刚
Jake: Roasted soybean flour just now.
Lucia:对就这刚才我手一抖撕歪了
Lucia: Yeah, just now my hand shook and I tore it crooked.
Alice:啊
Alice: Ah.
Jake:我要玩啊我要玩
Jake: I want to play, I want to play.
Lucia:这边这个比较齐
Lucia: This side is more even.
其他人:卧槽你看
Others: Whoa, look!
其他人:变这么好看了
Others: It looks so good now.
其他人:对哼
Others: Yeah, hmm.
Jake:玩手机玩了10分钟
Jake: Played with the phone for 10 minutes.
Jake:变好看了
Jake: It looks good now.
Tasha:就这样抖就行
Tasha: Just shake it like this.
其他人:变好看了
Others: It looks good now.
Jake:哼
Jake: Hmm.
Jake:好了下一个
Jake: Okay, next one.
Tasha:等等等等等等
Tasha: Wait, wait, wait, wait.
Lucia:哎
Lucia: Hey.
Lucia:底下稍微有点湿
Lucia: The bottom is a bit wet.
Lucia:没事这个
Lucia: It's okay though.
Lucia:这个纸不剩水可以
Lucia: This paper doesn't absorb water, so it's fine.
Tasha:哎呀哎呀没事没事
Tasha: Oh no, it's okay, it's okay.
Lucia:那也行时间长了他会不会透
Lucia: Will it seep through if it stays too long?
Lucia:要不还是拿张纸擦一下
Lucia: Maybe we should wipe it with another paper.
Lucia:炫我嘴里
Lucia: Show off my mouth.
Jake:来来来张嘴
Jake: Come on, open your mouth.
Jake:哈哈哈哈哈哈这一一眼睛这是
Jake: Hahaha, look at this, this eye.
Jake:这个还是要什么什么色
Jake: Does this still need some color?
Tasha:抹茶的哦抹茶的
Tasha: Matcha flavor, oh, matcha.
其他人:我靠高级
Others: Wow, fancy.
Jake:确实确实厉害
Jake: Indeed, quite impressive.
Jake:那剩下来怎么办
Jake: So what do we do with the leftovers?
Jake:只能倒进嘴里
Jake: Just pour it into the mouth.
Jake:哈哈哈这怎么办啊
Jake: Hahaha, what should we do?
Jake:这个倒掉这个倒掉
Jake: Pour it out, pour it out.
Alice:打这个
Alice: Hit this.
Jake:那好吧倒这里倒这里
Jake: Alright then, pour it here, pour it here.
Jake:倒真的哈哈哈好
Jake: Really pour it, haha, good.
Lucia:会炫我脸上
Lucia: It will shine on my face.
Jake:那我现在鼠标上吧
Jake: Then I'll put it on the mouse now.
Jake:哈哈哈哈
Jake: Hahaha
Lucia:抹茶粉太贵了
Lucia: Matcha powder is too expensive.
Lucia:所以我不舍得这样子倒
Lucia: So I can't bear to pour it like this.
其他人:抹茶粉太贵了嗯
Others: Matcha powder is too expensive, yeah.
Alice:嗯
Alice: Yeah.
Jake:槽可以不用了
Jake: We don't need the slot anymore.
Jake:真的那我再多擦点
Jake: Really, then I'll wipe a bit more.
Alice:我靠真的好吃什么
Alice: Oh my, it's really delicious.
Jake:哈哈哈哈哈哈哈跟没家一样
Jake: Hahahahaha, it's like there's nothing added.
Lucia:跟没加一样
Lucia: It's like there's nothing added.
Jake:这是最高评价吗哈哈哈
Jake: Is this the highest praise? Hahaha
Jake:抹茶粉多贵啊
Jake: Matcha powder is so expensive.
Tasha:左边这跟右边这不一样
Tasha: The left and the right sides are different.
Tasha:呃一克一克两块钱
Tasha: Uh, one gram is two yuan.
Jake:我去一克两块钱
Jake: Wow, two yuan for one gram.
Lucia:哇那比黄金便宜点
Lucia: Wow, that's cheaper than gold.
Jake:哈哈哈哈哈哈那便宜好多
Jake: Hahahahaha, it's way cheaper.
Jake:确实
Jake: Indeed.
Jake:没关系没关系
Jake: It's okay, it's okay.
Jake:嗯
Jake: Hmm.
Alice:边角料全部都炫掉
Alice: Use up all the scraps.
Jake:哎
Jake: Hey.
Jake:还没撒粉呢
Jake: Haven't sprinkled the powder yet.
Jake:嗯那个对
Jake: Hmm, that, yes.
Jake:黄金还没撒呢
Jake: Haven't sprinkled the gold yet.
Jake:小黄金
Jake: Little gold.
其他人:我靠那一会没撒完
Others: Oh man, haven't finished sprinkling yet.
其他人:抹茶粉可以炫耀谁
Others: Who can show off matcha powder?
其他人:我很喜欢的
Others: I really like it.
Jake:好嘞好
Jake: Okay, sure.
Tasha:好嘞好这个抹茶饭挺好吃的
Tasha: Okay, sure, this matcha rice is quite tasty.
Tasha:好撒吧呵呵
Tasha: Okay, sprinkle it, haha.
Lucia:这这个也就刚倒这么一点撒
Lucia: This, this is just a little bit.
Tasha:啊喜喜斯科草莓
Tasha: Ah, Xixi Sike strawberry.
其他人:这是
Others: This is...
其他人:这是有排版的呀
Others: This is well-arranged.
其他人:我靠
Others: Oh man.
其他人:非常的高级
Others: Very high-end.
其他人:为什么一个6一个5个上面要放草莓
Other people: Why is there a strawberry on one 6 and five 5s?
Tasha:对
Tasha: Yeah
其他人:为什么一个6一个5个
Other people: Why is there one 6 and five 5s?
小薇 :被他偷偷吃了一个这个
Tasha: He secretly ate one of them.
Jake:其他人:
Jake: Other people:
其他人:那我再偷吃一个可乐
Other people: Then I'll secretly drink a Coke.
Tasha:你想吃哪个
Tasha: Which one do you want to eat?
其他人:你让我吃哪个
Other people: Which one will you let me eat?
Tasha:你想吃哪个吃哪个
Tasha: You can eat whichever you want.
Alice:还要再来点吗
Alice: Do you want some more?
Jake:还要还要还来点来点
Jake: Yes, more, more, give me more.
Alice:切不切
Alice: Should we cut it?
Jake:哎呀这个挪一挪
Jake: Oh, move this a bit.
Jake:哎
Jake: Hey
Tasha:呦我的天哪
Tasha: Oh my God.
Tasha:我的天哪
Jake:哦好吸
Jake: Oh, it absorbs well.
Tasha:确实这个奶油为啥这么洗
Tasha: Why is this cream so absorbent?
Tasha:因为本来不洗的
Tasha: Because it wasn't supposed to be.
Tasha:但是这个蛋挞太热了
Tasha: But the tart is too hot.
Jake:哦好好好好好交错
Jake: Oh, okay, okay, okay, mix it up.
Alice:快吃快吃
Alice: Hurry, eat, eat.
Alice:别拍了
Alice: Stop filming.
Alice:大家快吃
Alice: Everyone, eat up.
Jake:没关系
Jake: It's okay.
Jake:我每天都在这种surprising中
Jake: I'm always surprised every day.
Jake:来吃吃吃
Jake: Come on, eat, eat, eat.
Jake:大师您先吃您先吃
Jake: Master, you eat first, you eat first.
Tasha:您先吃
Tasha: You eat first.
Jake:您先吃下一个
Jake: You eat first, next one.
Tasha:下一个
Tasha: Next one.
Jake:哈哈哎
Jake: Haha, hey
Tasha:这个真的擦了吗
Tasha: Did you really clean this?
Lucia:擦了但是他那个渣就会粘在上面
Lucia: Cleaned it, but the crumbs stick on it.
Lucia:就是厨房纸会被他那个木头挂掉
Lucia: The kitchen paper gets caught on the wood.
Tasha:嗯嗯嗯明白
Tasha: Hmm, I see.
Lucia:所以我那那里面也垫一个
Lucia: So I put one inside as well.
Lucia:等一下我刚哎刚那个这个
Lucia: Wait, I just, hey, just this.
Tasha:啊
Tasha: Ah
Lucia:这个要垫一下吗
Lucia: Should we put a pad on this?
Jake:啊
Jake: Ah
Lucia:还是垫一下吧
Lucia: Still, let's put a cushion.
Tasha:这个行这个嗯
Tasha: This one works, yeah.
Tasha:哦这个很舒服
Tasha: Oh, this one's really comfy.
其他人:傻逼企鹅狗都别买
Others: Don't buy stupid penguin dogs.
Jake:什么意思啊
Jake: What do you mean?
其他人:没事我买这个
Others: It's okay, I'll buy this one.
其他人:就是我女朋友的前男友
Others: It's my girlfriend's ex-boyfriend.
其他人:送我女朋友的是企鹅
Others: He gave my girlfriend a penguin.
其他人:他送给他前男友的是企鹅啊
Others: He gave his ex-boyfriend a penguin.
其他人:他送给他前男友的是企鹅哦
Others: He gave his ex-boyfriend a penguin, oh.
Jake:然后
Jake: And then?
其他人:我女朋友的前男友送我女朋友的
Others: My girlfriend's ex-boyfriend gave my girlfriend a penguin.
其他人:也是企鹅
Others: Also a penguin.
Lucia:就是他被绿的那个啊
Lucia: That's the guy who got cheated on.
其他人:不是不是不是我现在的女朋友
Others: No, no, not my current girlfriend.
Tasha:你现在女朋友的前任
Tasha: Your current girlfriend's ex.
Alice:啊
Alice: Ah.
Lucia:哦
Lucia: Oh.
其他人:你天呐
Others: Oh my god.
Jake:建立了连接
Jake: Connection established.
Jake:collected
Jake: Collected.
Jake:好吃
Jake: Tasty.
其他人:好我立马辞职
Others: Fine, I'll resign immediately.
其他人:为了你我加入自己哈哈哈
Others: For you, I'll join myself, hahaha.
Katrina: 这种这种就是库存就几个的
Katrina: These are the ones with only a few in stock.
Katrina: 就一般是个人海淘
Katrina: Usually, individuals buy them overseas.
Jake:我先把这个收了吧
Jake: I'll take this first.
Katrina: 就是他们从官网下单
Katrina: They order from the official website.
Katrina: 然后要等一个月什么的
Katrina: Then have to wait a month or so.
Katrina: 然后这种的话就比较真
Katrina: So these are more authentic.
Jake:我靠这很难很难补汤
Jake: Man, this is really hard to make soup with.
Katrina: 要么就官网买
Katrina: Or just buy from the official website.
Katrina: 官网经常没货
Katrina: The official website often runs out of stock.
Jake:嗯
Jake: Hmm.
Katrina: 是买还是送人啊
Katrina: Is it for buying or gifting?
Katrina: 送人啊
Katrina: Gifting?
Katrina: 那就别送企鹅
Katrina: Then don't give a penguin.
Jake:Katrina:
Jake: Katrina.
Katrina: 对对对就买这个
Katrina: Yes, yes, just buy this one.
Katrina: 是甄选的
Katrina: It's selected.
Jake:我看看
Jake: Let me see.
Katrina: 非常的好看啊
Katrina: It's really beautiful.
Jake:这是狐狸对
Jake: This is a fox, right?
Alice:下面两个招呼
Alice: Next two greetings.
Katrina: 用一个容器
Katrina: Use a container.
Jake:容器
Jake: Container.
Jake:真圆
Jake: So round.
Katrina: 京东上多少有369
Katrina: It's 369 on JD.
Katrina: 有点过分了
Katrina: That's a bit too much.
Alice:他怎么溢
Alice: How is it overflowing?
Katrina: 价呢他这有217 咖啡液
Katrina: The price, it's 217 for the coffee liquid.
Alice:可以可以
Alice: Okay, okay.
Katrina: 就这个是吧好
Katrina: This one, right? Okay.
Katrina: 在这
Katrina: Here.
Katrina: 这个还要用咖啡液
Katrina: This still needs coffee liquid.
Alice:提拉米苏
Alice: Tiramisu.
Katrina: 我说我直接这么切了
Katrina: I said I'll just cut it directly.
Tasha:你切
Tasha: You cut it.
Tasha:但是你可以用那个切刀切咖啡叶
Tasha: But you can use that cutter to cut coffee leaves.
Tasha:对
Tasha: Yeah.
Jake:切切刀
Jake: Cutter.
Jake:切刀是什么
Jake: What's a cutter?
Lucia:那天那天杨老板切蛋糕那个刀吗
Lucia: That day, the knife Jake used to cut the cake?
Jake:哦哦
Jake: Oh, oh.
Jake:看到咖啡叶
Jake: I see the coffee leaves.
Jake:咖啡叶
Jake: Coffee leaves.
Jake:这个吗
Jake: Is it this one?
Tasha:呃也可以啊
Tasha: Uh, it can be.
Lucia:咖啡液是咱们那天那个绿色的那个吗
Lucia: The coffee liquid, was it that green one we had that day?
Lucia:就是这也行
Lucia: This can work too.
Jake:瑞幸咖啡业
Jake: Luckin Coffee's liquid.
Jake:都不知道为什么出现在这
Jake: I don't know why it's here.
Jake:不知道怎么是怎么就买了呢
Jake: I don't know how it was bought.
Lucia:他突然就出现在了需要用的地方
Lucia: It just suddenly appeared where needed.
Lucia:很好
Lucia: Great.
Katrina: 好有经验
Katrina: So experienced.
Jake:怎么怎么怎么买
Jake: How, how, how to buy it?
Katrina: 看他有经验
Katrina: Look, he's experienced.
Katrina: 这不可能只有149
Katrina: It can't be just 149.
Jake:这个200多块钱
Jake: This is over 200 yuan.
Katrina: 这个200多块钱而且还有溢价
Katrina: This is over 200 yuan and there's a premium too.
Jake:判断什么
Jake: Judging what?
其他人:他就看库存就能看出来
Others: He can tell just by looking at the stock.
其他人:这个东西他觉得真不真哦
Others: Whether he thinks it's real or not.
其他人:哎这还都响
Others: Wow, they all still make noise.
Jake:对新乐器
Jake: Yes, it's a new instrument.
Katrina: 但溢价也没必要
Katrina: 你你着急送人吗
Katrina: Are you in a hurry to give it to someone?
Katrina: 孩子那也不太急
Katrina: The kid isn't in that much of a rush.
送女生确实
Giving it to a girl is indeed...
其他人:确实哦这个咖啡液买还派上用场
Jake:呵呵板砖的是吧
Jake: Haha, it's a brick, right?
Jake:哈哈哈本来是想来缩的是吧哈哈哈
Jake: Hahaha, you were planning to bring it, right? Hahaha.
Lucia:本来是想夹带私货的是吧
Lucia: You were planning to bring your private stash, right?
Katrina: 我的小狮
Katrina: My little lion.
Katrina: 我的小狐狸
Katrina: My little fox.
Katrina: 我靠居然买那家
Katrina: Wow, you actually bought from that store.
Katrina: 马上就断货了
Katrina: It's going to be out of stock soon.
Lucia:没事
Lucia: It's okay.
Lucia:其实那个奶酪也是我夹带的私货
Lucia:不过反正也吃上了哈哈
Lucia: But anyway, we ate it. Haha.
Katrina: 我靠还没拍照
Katrina: Wow, I haven't even taken a photo yet.
其他人:我靠这摆盘有点怎么怎么
Others: Wow, this plating is a bit...
其他人:又低了一下头就已经摆完了
Others: Looked down for a second and it's already plated.
其他人:我操你吃完了
Others: Wow, you've already finished eating.
Jake:又低了一下头
Jake: Looked down for a second.
其他人:放上去放上去
Others: Put it on, put it on.
其他人: 放上去
Others: Put it on.
Jake:这一会再撒撒肉松
Jake: Sprinkle some more pork floss later.
Lucia:热水壶是不是俩都在楼上啊
Lucia: Are both the kettles upstairs?
Lucia:我去拿吧
Lucia: I'll go get them.
Lucia:啊楼下有吗
Lucia: Ah, is there one downstairs?
Alice:底下有
Alice: There's one downstairs.
Lucia:啊那行
Lucia: Ah, okay then.
Lucia:为什么要把他们强行塞在一起啊
Lucia: Why forcefully put them together?
Jake:方便拍照
Jake: Makes it easier to take photos.
Jake:咱还有道具呢
Jake: We also have props.
Jake:哈哈哈
Jake: Hahaha.
Jake:在后面再摆一个显得很多
Jake: Put another one behind to make it look like more.
Alice:你能不能把这个汇源果汁挡一下
Alice: Can you block this Huiyuan juice?
Jake:我们有整整两大盆
Jake: We have two whole big bowls.
Jake:现在还有什
Jake: What else do we have now?
Jake:还有什么
Jake: What else?
Alice:提拉米苏
Alice: Tiramisu.
Jake:提拉米苏
Jake: Tiramisu.
Jake:嗯
Jake: Hmm.
Lucia:要用哪个盒子呀
Lucia: Which box should we use?
Lucia:垫纸吗用这用这个盒吗还是
Lucia: Should we use this box with the paper or...?
Alice:用那个就行吧
Alice: Just use that one.
Lucia:那把这俩挪到一个上
Lucia: Then let's move these two into one.
Jake:对这个先洗洗
Jake: Yes, let's wash this first.
Jake:都是买的
Jake: They're all store-bought.
Jake:这玩意咋洗
Jake: How do you wash this thing?
Jake:刚刚路亚怎么洗
Jake: How did Luyah just wash it?
Jake:就擦了擦是吧
Jake: Just wiped it, right?
Lucia:我拿这个擦的
Lucia: I wiped it with this.
Lucia:就是沾点水擦
Lucia: Just with a bit of water.
Lucia:但是就是因为这是木头的
Lucia: But since it's wooden,
Lucia:所以它就是上面的
Lucia: it might have splinters.
Lucia:有可能会有刺
Lucia: So the surface...
Jake:可能得
Jake: Might need...
Lucia:会把这个稍微刮下来
Lucia: Might get scraped a bit.
Jake:换几张纸
Jake: Change a few papers.
Jake:那厨那那厨房纸有用吗
Jake: Would kitchen paper work?
Lucia:呃那个好像不能直接用
Lucia: Uh, that one might not be usable directly.
Lucia:就是上面不是有那个洗洁精吗
Lucia: Because it has dish soap on it.
Lucia:如果你直接擦好就会留在上面
Lucia: If you wipe it directly, it will stay on it.
Lucia:或者能直接洗一下可能也行
Lucia: Or you could wash it directly, that might work.
Jake:那我过水了
Jake: I'll rinse it then.
Jake:行我觉得我直接洗一洗
Jake: Okay, I think I'll just wash it.
Jake:那个大碗是吧哦挺好
Jake: That big bowl, right? Oh, nice.
Jake:就这个就
Jake: Just this one...
Alice:这个吧
Alice: This one, right?
Lucia:这个不太行
Lucia: This one isn't quite right.
Jake:好这边可以
Jake: Okay, this one is fine.
Alice:这个或者这个这个吧
Alice: This one or this one, this one then.
Alice:这个底深
Alice: This one has a deep bottom.
Lucia:这有俩不过这俩应该是一样大的
Lucia: There are two here, but these two should be the same size.
Alice:用这个吧
Alice: Let's use this one.
Lucia:哦那个碗
Lucia: Oh, that bowl.
Lucia:对那碗能沉的更深一点
Lucia: Yeah, that bowl can sink a bit deeper.
Alice:这是干净的
Alice: This is clean.
Tasha:不用擦不用擦
Tasha: No need to wipe, no need to wipe.
Jake:戴眼镜吧
Jake: Put on your glasses.
Alice:手指饼干呢
Alice: Where are the ladyfingers?
Lucia:这要擦一下吗
Lucia: Do we need to wipe this?
Tasha:拿出来了
Tasha: Got them out.
Tasha:手指饼干
Tasha: Ladyfingers.
Tasha:不用了不用了
Tasha: No need, no need.
Lucia:要要
Lucia: Yes, we do.
Alice:蘸一下
Alice: Dip it a bit.
其他人:一下蘸
Others: Just dip it a bit.
其他人:一下咖啡蘸一下那个蘸一下咖啡
Others: Dip it in the coffee, dip it in the coffee.
Alice:蘸一下那个
Alice: Dip that one.
Alice:没事等一会吧
Alice: Never mind, let's wait a bit.
其他人:然后我
Others: And then I...
Alice:不烤就直接放那
Alice: Don't bake it, just place it there.
Alice:蘸一下然后放在那个夹层里
Alice: Dip it and then put it in the layer.
Shure: 外面是不是有点小冷
Shure: Isn't it a bit cold outside?
Shure: 谁开的 16度
Shure: Who set it to 16 degrees?
Jake:京爷京爷这就是京爷
Jake: It's Jing, Jing did it.
Shure: 你在家不挨揍吗
Shure: Don't you get scolded at home?
Jake:京爷
Jake: Jing.
Alice:你是突然出现的吗
Alice: Did you just appear suddenly?
Alice:刚刚你在这吗
Alice: Were you just here?
Jake:甩舌头非常
Jake: Flicking your tongue a lot.
Jake:哈哈哈赶紧赶紧赶紧挑赶紧挑
Jake: Haha, hurry up, hurry up, pick quickly.
Shure: 牛排呢吃没了都
Shure: Where's the steak? All gone?
Shure: 牛排吃没了
Shure: The steak is all gone.
Jake:我怎么调啊
Jake: How should I adjust it?
Jake:我靠为什么哦
Jake: Damn, why is this...
Alice:给
Alice: Here you go.
Jake:26了都行
Jake: 26 is fine.
Alice:这呢
Alice: What about this?
京爷这个这个
Jing: This, this.
Alice:咖啡液
Alice: Coffee liquid.
京爷哦奥提拉米苏是吧
Jing: Oh, it's for tiramisu, right?
Tasha:对果然2,000
Tasha: Yeah, indeed 2,000.
京爷哦这里边啊对这搁的是什么呢
Jing: Oh, inside here, yeah, what's in it?
Lucia:啊对
Lucia: Ah, right.
Lucia:这搁的是什么
Lucia: What's this?
Jake:手指饼干
Jake: Ladyfingers.
Lucia:手指饼干哦
Lucia: Oh, ladyfingers.
Jake:哦想吃了已经
Jake: Oh, already craving it.
京爷我靠高级
Tasha:哎你这样碰太多了
Tasha: Hey, you're touching it too much.
Alice:太快了
Alice: Too fast.
Tasha:不行太快了
Tasha: No, it's too fast.
Tasha:这饼干什么都不能要了不行了
Tasha: These cookies are useless now.
其他人:没事没事我这还有几个
Others: It's okay, it's okay. I have a few more.
Jake:嗯你还能吃几个
Jake: Hmm, how many more can you eat?
Tasha:这几个都不能要了
Tasha: These ones are all useless now.
Alice:对我来吧
Alice: Yeah, let me do it.
Alice:拿个勺子
Alice: Get a spoon.
Tasha:对拿筷子
Tasha: Yeah, get chopsticks.
Tasha:这几个把咖啡液全部都吸走了
Tasha: These have soaked up all the coffee.
Tasha:而且没事没事
Tasha: But it's okay, it's okay.
Tasha:问题不是很大
Tasha: It's not a big problem.
Jake:没事你先吃了吧要不
Jake: It's fine, you can eat first if you want.
Jake:哈哈哈
Jake: Hahaha.
Tasha:继续吧而且咖啡液也还有好嘞
Tasha: Keep going, there's still enough coffee.
Jake:好嘞
Jake: Okay.
Lucia:那几个要不要弄一下
Lucia: Should we do something about those?
Shure: 我想吃个咸鸭蛋
Shure: I want to eat a salted duck egg.
Jake:咸鸭蛋
Jake: Salted duck egg.
Shure: 吃过吧小伙伴
Shure: Have you tried it, guys?
Jake:吃还是常吃
Jake: Yeah, we eat it often.
Tasha:要不再弄个咖啡
Tasha: Should we make another coffee?
Tasha:不够了够
Tasha: Not enough, enough.
Alice:吗要重新弄一份
Alice: Should we make a new batch?
其他人:没事没事还有那个
Others: It's okay, there's still some left.
其他人:算了不行我还给你手穿了
Others: Forget it, I can't do it anymore, I'll just pierce my hand.
其他人:然后再来一盘就能吃了
Others: Then make another plate and it'll be ready to eat.
Tasha:对还要再来一盘
Tasha: Yes, we need another plate.
Tasha:就就这些
Tasha: Just these.
其他人:没有没有
Others: No, no.
其他人:那还有一包
Others: There's still one more pack.
Lucia:这个可以放回去
Lucia: This can be put back.
Alice:要把它舀出来
Alice: We need to scoop it out.
Tasha:没事
Tasha: It's okay.
Tasha:其实没什么味道
Tasha: It doesn't really have much flavor.
其他人:这上面不是撒了一层糖吗
Others: Isn't there a layer of sugar on top?
其他人:为什么这个有菠萝味啊
Others: Why does this taste like pineapple?
Alice:里面放菠萝了
Alice: There's pineapple inside.
其他人:我放菠萝
Others: I put pineapple in.
Alice:夹带了哈哈哈
Alice: You sneaked it in, haha.
Jake:夹带了哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈
Jake: You sneaked it in, hahaha.
Alice:上面有没有的
Alice: Is there any on top?
Alice:上面没有
Alice: There's none on top.
Jake:我也整一个
Jake: I'll make one too.
Alice:你失败了
Alice: You failed.
Alice:刘帅受到了大家的批评
Alice: Choiszt was criticized by everyone.
Shure: 就一个人批评这个
Shure: Only one person criticized it.
Jake:就一个人批评
Jake: Only one person criticized.
Jake:对我这个
Jake: Yeah, for mine.
Jake:来表扬一下
Jake: Come, praise me.
Jake:这有没有菠萝
Jake: Is there any pineapple in this?
Jake:不一定没有
Jake: Not necessarily none.
Alice:没有
Alice: None.
Jake:这这有菠萝吗
Jake: Is there pineapple in this?
Alice:这个没有
Alice: This one doesn't have.
Alice:没有了你看你要是不拿走刚刚好
Alice: If you don't take it away, it's just right.
Alice:这四个
Alice: These four.
其他人:怎么挤就是拿手上捏
Others: How to squeeze it, just press it with your hand.
Alice:谁来捏
Alice: Who will press it?
其他人:也可以来几个
Others: You can make a few more.
其他人:没有提拉米苏味的或者其他味的
Others: No tiramisu flavor or other flavors?
其他人:抹茶味的
Others: Matcha flavor.
Alice:怎么样都是需要手指饼干的
Alice: Anyway, you need ladyfingers.
其他人:或者可乐味
Others: Or cola flavor.
Jake:每追回一台
Jake: Each retrieves one.
Shure: 真香
Shure: Smells so good.
Jake:你听说过高油咸鸭蛋吗
Jake: Have you heard of high-oil salted duck egg?
Shure: 听说过
Shure: Heard of it.
其他人:小说嘛嗯
Others: Novel, right?
其他人:非常的真的吗
Others: Really, huh?
Shure: 真的吗
Shure: Really?
其他人:好吃嗯
Others: Delicious, huh?
Shure: 真的是王胜奇的小说吗
Shure: Is it really Wang Shengqi's novel?
其他人:好像是个高油鸭蛋
Others: Looks like a high-fat duck egg.
Shure: 我是个章鱼
Shure: I am an octopus.
Shure: 我不知道
Shure: I don't know.
其他人:我也不知道
Others: I don't know either.
其他人:我只是撕
Others: I'm just tearing.
其他人:要捏一个嘛
Others: Should we knead one?
Tasha:不知道该怎么办
Tasha: Don't know what to do.
Jake:其他人:
Jake: Others:
Alice:把这个搁这这底下
Alice: Put this under here.
Jake:其他人:
Jake: Others:
其他人:好吃的吃这个你也吃
Others: This is delicious, you should try it too.
Shure: 牛排怎么这么受欢迎呢
Shure: Why is steak so popular?
Jake:是直接吃吗
Jake: Do we eat it directly?
Jake:啊饱了和和和会吧
Jake: Ah, I'm full, yeah yeah yeah.
Shure: 我出来都没了
Shure: It's gone when I came out.
Jake:休息一下休息一下
Jake: Take a break, take a break.
Shure: 我吃了个饺子
Shure: I had a dumpling.
其他人:这奶油吗
Others: Is this cream?
Alice:这是
Alice: It is.
其他人:是这是什么东西
Others: What is this stuff?
Jake:提拉米苏啊
Jake: Tiramisu.
Alice:这
Alice: This.
其他人:提拉米苏
Others: Tiramisu.
Jake:他可能烤完之后就是方方正正的
Jake: It might be square after baking.
Alice:有没有可能等会切一下就是了
Alice: Maybe we can cut it later.
Alice:这不加还需要再来一层
Alice: This needs another layer.
Jake:他烤完之后他就变成了一层又一层
Jake: After baking, it turns into layers.
Tasha:就一包还有一包妙啊
Tasha: Just one package, and another package, amazing.
Alice:还有一包
Alice: Another package.
Alice:再来再来再来调一层
Alice: Let's add another layer.
Jake:我骑一会马
Jake: I'm going to ride a horse for a bit.
其他人:我得亏我得亏
Others: I'm lucky, I'm lucky.
其他人:抖音买了个打火机
Others: Bought a lighter on Douyin.
Alice:还差200克热水
Alice: Still need 200 grams of hot water.
Alice:再烧200克
Alice: Boil another 200 grams.
Jake:师傅没开机啊
Jake: The master hasn't turned it on.
Jake:大师啊
Jake: Master!
Jake:眼睛怎么再再整一下
Jake: How about fixing the eyes again?
Jake:再给人再给人整一下
Jake: Fix it again for someone.
Alice:烧20克就行了
Alice: Just boil 20 grams.
Alice:不用200200克就行了
Alice: No need, 200 grams is enough.
Alice:你加的越多烧的越慢
Alice: The more you add, the slower it burns.
Lucia:好的倒点
Lucia: Okay, I'll pour a bit.
其他人:那其实如果你这个都泡了以后泡的话
Others: Actually, if you soak it all, then soak it later,
Lucia:呃呃
Lucia: Uh-huh.
其他人:就刚才那点那几个饼干也应该加进去
Others: You should also add those few biscuits from earlier.
其他人:就也可以加进去先烤开了
Others: Just add them in and bake them first.
Alice:你抄底的时候可能拖不住
Alice: When you scrape the bottom, it might not hold.
其他人:但是你现在加完了以后
Others: But now after you add it,
其他人:他底下不也没泡了
Others: the bottom isn't soaked, right?
Shure: 我的可乐呢
Shure: Where's my cola?
其他人:就你现在加完这个
Others: After you add this,
其他人:这不也稀的吗
Others: isn't it still thin?
其他人:那你底下那种那边有个空盒
Others: There's an empty box over there at the bottom.
Jake:那没人喝的可乐你喝没事还会冷藏
Jake: If no one drinks the cola, you can have it, it can still be chilled.
Alice:没事还会冷藏
Alice: It's fine, it can still be chilled.
Jake:这里头
Jake: Inside here.
Shure: 哎卧槽
Shure: Ah, crap.
Tasha:我在抽水
Tasha: I'm draining water.
Shure: 我的尾巴夹住了
Shure: My tail is stuck.
Alice:别烧了
Alice: Stop burning it.
Shure: 你的你的眼镜没电了
Shure: Your glasses ran out of battery.
Katrina: 可能是没内存了
Katrina: Maybe it's out of memory.
Jake:我嗯
Jake: I guess.
Shure: 可能是你的脸突然把它抱内存了
Shure: Maybe your face suddenly filled its memory.
Shure: 哈哈哈
Shure: Hahaha.
Jake:插根插插电吧
Jake: Plug it in.
Jake:应该还是有
Jake: There should still be power.
Shure: 我们是不是没有排练歌曲啊家人们
Shure: Did we not rehearse the song, everyone?
Jake:这即兴唱呗啊
Jake: We can just improvise.
Shure: 啊哈哈哈
Shure: Ah hahaha.
Jake:即兴唱呗
Jake: Just improvise.
Jake:要不就还有QA QA QA
Jake: Or we can do some QA, QA, QA.
Shure: 哦QA也没做
Shure: Oh, we didn't do QA either.
Jake:做一个呗
Jake: Let's do one.
Alice:还有藏币
Alice: And the hidden coins.
Jake:藏币现藏币
Jake: Hidden coins, yes.
Lucia:哦
Lucia: Oh.
Jake:大家大大伙
Jake: Everyone, everyone.
Jake:大伙先藏币吧
Jake: Let's start with the hidden coins.
Alice:币呢
Alice: Where's the coin?
Jake:币呢币在这这
Jake: The coin? The coin is here.
Jake:是是是是是币吗
Jake: Is this the coin?
Alice:这是币吗
Alice: Is this the coin?
Jake:不是不是
Jake: No, it's not.
Alice:还没装修呢
Alice: It's not done yet.
Lucia:对
Lucia: Yeah.
Lucia:每天都有好多事
Lucia: There's so much to do every day.
Jake:那工人怎么
Jake: What about the workers?
Jake:咱怎么办
Jake: What should we do?
Jake:工人已经救不了了是吧
Jake: Can't save the workers, right?
Jake:哈哈哈哈
Jake: Haha.
Jake:工人哈哈哈
Jake: The workers, haha.
Jake:一直是失一直是失控的状态哈哈
Jake: They've been out of control all the time, haha.
Jake:我操
Jake: Damn.
Lucia:那要不摆烂吧
Lucia: Why don't we just let it be?
Jake:哈
Jake: Huh?
Shure: 快勾人快快勾人
Shure: Hurry and hook someone, hurry!
Shure: 勾人快快
Shure: Hook someone, hurry!
Shure: 你不急吗勾
Shure: Aren't you in a hurry? Hook!
Jake:哈哈
Jake: Haha.
Shure: 我好急
Shure: I'm so anxious.
Jake:哈哈哈哈哈哈你回头
Jake: Haha, you look back.
Jake:你回头再测一下
Jake: You look back and test it again.
Jake:哈哈哈
Jake: Haha.
Jake:你今天晚上当着我坐着别测一下
Jake: You sit here tonight and test it again.
Shure: 啊我们今天
Shure: Ah, we today...
Jake:哈哈哈来吧
Jake: Haha, come on.
Shure: 来吧
Shure: Come on.
Jake:屁人训练计划
Jake: Training plan for lazy people.
Shure: 把那个投投个屏开始给你测一下
Shure: Cast the screen and start testing it for you.
Jake:哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈
Jake: Hahaha.
Lucia:哈
Lucia: Ha.
Shure: 哈哈哈
Shure: Haha.
Shure: 公开处刑
Shure: Public execution.
Jake:我试试是不是这个没开啊
Jake: Let me see if this is off.
Alice:哦
Alice: Oh.
Jake:哦他这个没开
Jake: Oh, it's off.
Jake:确实没开
Jake: It really is off.
Jake:然后这个肯定是没插
Jake: And this one isn't plugged in for sure.
Jake:这个是要不就插好了
Jake: How about plugging this in?
其他人:插好了
Others: It's plugged in.
Jake:有电不是
Jake: There's power, right?
Jake:有电但是没开
Jake: There's power but it's not on.
Jake:开了就就
Jake: If you turn it on...
Jake:他显然没充电啊
Jake: It clearly hasn't charged.
Jake:我靠这100%开玩笑的啊
Jake: Oh man, this is 100% a joke.
Jake:呵呵就是就是
Jake: Haha, it's just...
Jake:他没开他有电但是没开
Jake: It's not on. It has power but it's not on.
Jake:哎这其他人:
Jake: Oh, this...
Jake:这咋不开啊
Jake: Why isn't it turning on?
其他人:那没电了呀
Others: It's out of battery.
Jake:对要开机了
Jake: Yeah, it needs to be turned on.
Jake:他得一直闪着他才有电
Jake: It needs to keep flashing to have power.
其他人:所以他机了是吧
Others: So it's on, right?
Jake:他机了不是不是不是你插
Jake: It's on. No, no, no, you plug it in...
Jake:了呀你
Jake: Yeah, you...
Jake:他要有电
Jake: It needs to have power.
Jake:其他人:
Jake: Others:
其他人:充电宝充电宝有电OK
Others: The power bank has power, OK.
Jake:但是你开着的时候他在充电
Jake: But when you turn it on, it charges.
Jake:他刚刚没有显示就没有电
Jake: It didn't show just now, so it had no power.
Jake:就是没有
Jake: Just no...
Jake:没有在供电
Jake: No power supply.
Jake:就这个意思
Jake: That's what it means.
Jake:现在
Jake: Now...
其他人:在这充电吧
Others: Charge it here.
Jake:啊这个在充电
Jake: Ah, this is charging.
Lucia:这是您刚才擦过的吗
Lucia: Did you just wipe this?
Lucia:那放的那个
Lucia: That one you put down.
Jake:对
Jake: Yes.
Lucia:感觉已经控干了
Lucia: Feels like it's already dry.
Jake:好嘞
Jake: Alright.
Jake:这个就是在充电
Jake: This is charging now.
Jake:给他充一会吧
Jake: Let it charge for a while.
Alice:买的居然刚刚好
Alice: It fits just right.
其他人:对对
Others: Yeah, yeah.
Alice:一般就靠铺两层
Alice: Usually, it just needs two layers.
其他人:我觉得
Others: I think...
其他人:不然不如你直接把这个都搁里边
Others: Otherwise, you could just put this all inside.
其他人::然后把这个稍微放里边
Others: Then put this in a little bit.
Alice:不行那样会把底下的底给铺
Alice: No, that will cover the bottom.
其他人:搞这么专业
Others: Doing it so professionally.
其他人:这是专业脚
Others: This is professional level.
其他人:别学到这个是哪里
Others: Don't learn this from somewhere else.
Lucia:这还有两根耶
Lucia: There are still two more here.
Alice:这两根别浪费了
Alice: Don't waste these two.
其他人:这是干嘛的茶
Others: What's this tea for?
Alice:直接用手吧
Alice: Just use your hands.
Alice:你那个你那个有底
Alice: That one has a bottom.
其他人:为什么为什么这样
Others: Why do it like this?
Tasha:你别搞那么快啊
Tasha: Don't do it so fast.
其他人:为什么你这样子搞这么快啊
Others: Why are you doing it so fast?
Shure: 怎么屡教不改呢刘帅
Shure: Why do you keep repeating mistakes, Choiszt?
Jake:刘帅哈哈怎么还在放呢
Jake: Choiszt, haha, why are you still putting it?
Jake:哈哈哈
Jake: Hahaha
其他人:等会再放等会再放
Others: Wait a bit before putting it in.
Jake:你等会再放你等会再放等会再放啊
Jake: Wait a bit before putting it in, wait a bit.
Jake:哎呀完了
Jake: Oh no, it's over.
Jake:太太太太太太太太太太太太太太太
Jake: Too too too...
Jake:太太太太太太太太太太
Jake:太太太太
Jake: Too too...
Jake:太太太太太
Jake:太太太太太太太太太
Jake: Too too too...
Shure: 哎
Shure: Hey
其他人:因为我感觉他真的已经非常重要
Others: Because I feel like it's really important.
Shure: 就是你
Shure: It's you.
Jake:行行行开除开除开除
Jake: Alright, fired, fired, fired.
Jake:好换一个换一个你
Jake: Alright, switch, switch to you.
其他人:你等他
Others: Wait for him.
其他人:你等他摆完你再放你等他摆完你再放
Others: Wait for him to finish before you put it in.
其他人:我知道我知道
Others: I know, I know.
Jake:你知道个球
Jake: You know nothing.
Jake:你知道哈哈哈
Jake: You know, hahaha.
其他人:好好的我错了但是我下次继续
Others: Fine, fine, I was wrong, but I'll do it again next time.
其他人:心里有数心里有数心里有数
Others: I got it, I got it, I got it.
Jake:有哈哈
Jake: Got it, haha.
其他人:哈哈哈来
Others: Hahaha, come on.
其他人:那怎么就多一层啊
Others: How come there's an extra layer?
Alice:无妨哈哈
Alice: No worries, haha.
Jake:哈哈哈多吃一口多好
Jake: Hahaha, have another bite, it's great.
Jake:这是尖锐你知道吧哈哈哈
Jake: This is sharp, you know? Hahaha.
其他人:哈就不能让你多吃一口
Others: Haha, can't let you have another bite.
其他人:不行这个ESP真的不
Others: No way, this ESP really doesn't...
其他人:这这这叫什么人格
Others: What kind of personality is this?
Alice:荣格荣格包围
Alice: Jung, surrounded by Jung.
Lucia:荣格巴韦
Lucia: Jung-Bawei.
其他人:芭蕾说的非常的不准
Others: Ballet said it very inaccurately.
其他人:里面可能是人在骗你了
Others: Maybe someone inside is deceiving you.
其他人:啥意思没事
Others: What do you mean? It's fine.
Lucia:就是那个MBTI
Lucia: It's that MBTI.
Lucia:他原本是荣格巴韦理论然后脱胎的
Lucia: It originally came from Jung-Bawei theory and then evolved.
Lucia:一个一个人格模型测试
Lucia: A personality model test.
其他人:这这一层是平这波
Others: This, this level is even, this wave...
其他人:这波无法
Others: This wave is impossible.
其他人:开但是有点浪费
Others: Open, but it's a bit wasteful.
Alice:没事你剩下你可以吃
Alice: It's fine, you can eat the rest.
Alice:然后现场就吃掉
Alice: Then just eat it right here.
Alice:确实现场就吃
Alice: Really, just eat it here.
其他人:哎这其实也可以塞下是吧
Others: Hey, this can actually fit, right?
其他人:就其他的啊
Others: Like the others.
Alice:现场就吃
Alice: Just eat it here.
Alice:你准备几个小葱花
Alice: You prepare a few scallions.
Alice:咱们现场吃掉它好吃吗
Alice: We'll eat it right here, is it tasty?
其他人:所以这个蛋挞是我们自己开的书吗
Others: So, did we make this tart ourselves?
其他人:还是买好的书
Others: Or did we buy it?
其他人:买好的那个
Others: Bought it.
其他人:哦
Others: Oh.
Jake:我们来b了
Jake: We're coming to B.
Jake:我们来b
Jake:哦哦可能在这里边
Jake: Oh oh, might be here.
Lucia:哎我今天早上还看见他了
Lucia: Hey, I saw him this morning.
Jake:b在哪啊
Jake: Where's B?
Jake:你知道吗
Jake: Do you know?
Alice:吃吧吃吧
Alice: Eat, eat.
Alice:好吧最后一个
Alice: Alright, the last one.
Alice:等一下还剩几个我们吃掉
Alice: Wait, how many are left? Let's finish them.
其他人:还有6 还有8个啊
Others: There are 6, 8 left.
其他人:6个哎这还有7个
Others: 6, hey, there are 7 left.
Jake:呃
Jake: Uh.
其他人:什么东西
Others: What is it?
Jake:币
Jake: Coin.
Lucia:我们的那个最后一天
Lucia: Our last day.
Jake:您您知道吗
Jake: Do you know?
其他人:没币
Others: No coin.
Lucia:作为通货的那个贴纸
Lucia: The sticker as currency.
Jake:不知道
Jake: No idea.
Jake:没币在哪
Jake: Where's the coin?
Alice:桌子上好嘞
Alice: On the table.
Jake:哪个桌子上
Jake: Which table?
Jake:这个桌子上
Jake: This table?
其他人:b吗
Others: Is it B?
Jake:好咱还有更多的桌子吗
Jake: Do we have more tables?
Lucia:咱还有更多的桌子吗
Lucia: Do we have more tables?
Jake:呵呵b
Jake: Haha, B.
Lucia:这是
Lucia: This is...
其他人:我看看b长什么样
Others: Let me see what B looks like.
Jake:你现在很难知道我长什么样子
Jake: It's hard to know what I look like now.
Alice:真的吗啊这是贴画呀啊贴画呀
Alice: Really? Oh, it's a sticker, a sticker.
其他人:这是b吗
Others: Is this B?
Alice:啊不是这个贴画吗
Alice: Oh, isn't this a sticker?
Lucia:我没说你说的
Lucia: I didn't say you said it.
Lucia:我说不是我拿的这个手机
Lucia: I said it's not this phone I took.
其他人:这不是币吗
Others: Isn't this a coin?
Jake:不是不是不是不是b
Jake: No, no, it's not B.
其他人:不是b
Others: It's not B.
Jake:b是圆的
Jake: B is round.
Jake:圆圆的圆的
Jake: Round, round.
Jake:贴纸贴纸贴纸贴纸贴纸
Jake: Stickers, stickers, stickers.
Jake:确实藏挺好啊
Jake: It's really well hidden.
Lucia:确实藏挺好
Lucia: It is well hidden.
Lucia:哈哈哈我们自己都找不见了
Lucia: Haha, we can't even find it ourselves.
Jake:呵呵呵呵呵呵呵呵呵呵呵呵呵呵呵
Jake: Hahahahahahahahaha.
Lucia:对对对已经藏好了
Lucia: Yeah, it's well hidden.
Jake:我
Jake: I...
其他人:能藏在哪啊
Others: Where can it be hidden?
Jake:不是呵呵
Jake: No, haha.
Lucia:现在是bond环节就大家一起找哈哈哈
Lucia: Now it's bonding time, everyone look together, haha.
Jake:藏找到了
Jake: Found it.
其他人:找到币了
Others: Found the coin.
Jake:藏挺好藏
Jake: Hidden pretty well.
Jake:藏哪了
Jake: Where did you hide it?
Lucia:就在桌上
Lucia: Just on the table.
Jake:哈哈哈
Jake: Hahaha.
Lucia:哎上面的桌子上啊原来是
Lucia: Oh, on top of the table, really.
Jake:哦高级
Jake: Oh, fancy.
Shure: 藏到你的
Shure: Hidden in your...
Jake:哈哈哈哈
Jake: Hahahaha.
Shure: 哈哈哈
Shure: Hahaha.
Lucia:哈哈哈哈
Lucia: Hahahaha.
其他人:是不是这个
Others: Is it this one?
其他人:就是这个
Others: It's this one.
其他人: 不是就是这个
Others: No, it's this one.
Jake:哈哈哈哈
Jake: Hahahaha.
Jake:什么意思啊
Jake: What does this mean?
Lucia:贴了个贴纸
Lucia: Stuck a sticker.
Jake:哦哦哦这也能当币吧
Jake: Oh, oh, oh, this can be used as currency, right?
Lucia:这也能当币吧
Lucia: This can be used as currency, right?
Jake:啊可以可
Jake: Ah, it can.
Jake:以当币这个算
Jake: It can be used as currency, this counts.
Jake:这这这算一分的吧
Jake: This, this, this counts as one point, right?
Jake:这类似于一块的
Jake: This is like one unit.
Jake:哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈
Jake: Hahahahahahahahaha.
Shure: 这是洋 币
Shure: This is foreign currency.
Alice:就只有16多了
Alice: Just over 16.
Jake:16的
Jake: 16.
Shure: 有吧 150个啊行
Shure: There should be 150, right?
Katrina: 内存
Katrina: Memory.
Jake:1616 够16
Jake: 16, 16, enough for 16.
Jake:够16 再干20分钟
Jake: Enough for 16, then another 20 minutes.
Alice:如果他没存储了自己断了
Alice: If it runs out of storage, it will stop automatically.
Alice:他应该是会存着吧
Alice: It should save itself, right?
Jake:对会存会存
Jake: Yes, it will save, it will save.
Katrina: 你也见不得人
Katrina: You can't show your face either.
Katrina: 你别笑话我你喂
Katrina: Don't laugh at me, hey.
Lucia:我藏自己房间吗
Lucia: Should I hide in my room?
Jake:来我藏自己房间吗
Jake: Should I hide in my room?
Jake:不用藏房间
Jake: No need to hide in the room.
Lucia:主要是藏房间的话
Lucia: But if I hide in the room...
Jake:不藏房间
Jake: Don't hide in the room.
Lucia:啊那就好
Lucia: Ah, that's good.
Jake:就在外边
Jake: It's just outside.
Lucia:要不然行李没地放
Lucia: Otherwise, there'd be no place for the luggage.
Alice:藏那上面呗
Alice: Hide it up there.
Jake:不能让他们爬
Jake: They can't climb up.
Jake:不能让他们碰到相机
Jake: They can't touch the cameras.
Jake:燕子可以不能爬相机
Jake: The swallows can stay, but they can't climb on the cameras.
Alice:机能藏这里面
Alice: The camera can be hidden in here.
Alice:哎这怎么连个拉锁都没有
Alice: Hey, why is there no zipper?
Jake:我去哈哈哈
Jake: I'll go, hahaha.
Lucia:你们到底藏哪了
Lucia: Where did you guys hide it?
Shure: 我们还没藏呢啊
Shure: We haven't hidden it yet.
Jake:你就我们找到了找
Jake: Just find it, we found it.
Jake:藏这了藏这了就
Jake: Hide it here, just hide it here.
Lucia:哈哈哈 150坏了
Lucia: Hahaha, 150 is broken.
Jake:150 我们匀个50来藏还是多少来着
Jake: 150, should we split 50 to hide, or how much was it?
Shure: 用来藏2020
Shure: Use it to hide 20.
Jake:藏个20吧
Jake: Hide 20 then.
Lucia:20很难藏这么大
Lucia: 20 is hard to hide, it's so big.
Jake:藏20吧能藏在每个人的房间吗
Jake: Hide 20, can it be hidden in everyone's room?
Jake:不能不能就20吧
Jake: If not, just hide 20.
Alice:藏这吗
Alice: Hide it here?
Jake:藏他20底下能让嘉宾往下爬
Jake: Hide 20 of them, can the guests climb down?
Alice:就在底下
Alice: Just below.
Katrina: 下能让嘉宾往下爬
Katrina: Can the guests climb down?
Alice:他不一定敢
Alice: He might not dare.
Alice:他不一定会爬呀
Alice: He might not climb.
Jake:藏他20个哈
Jake: Hide 20 of them.
Shure: ECO friendly
Shure: ECO friendly.
其他人:是不是ECO friend
Others: Is it ECO friendly?
其他人:我以为是environmental friend
Others: I thought it was environmental friend.
Shure: 不知道
Shure: I don't know.
Jake:呃是都可以都可以都可以
Jake: Uh, it can be both, it can be both.
Shure: 可能他要打把e后局吧
Shure: Maybe he wants to play an e-game later.
Jake:能冲进去
Jake: Can you rush in?
Alice:能冲进去 0
Alice: Can you rush in?
Jake:嗯
Jake: Yeah.
Lucia:我靠刚好20个
Lucia: Wow, exactly 20.
Alice:这每个都长不一样
Alice: Each one looks different.
Lucia:嗯应该是
Lucia: Hmm, it should be.
Alice:是多少组啊
Alice: How many sets are there?
Tasha:干嘛
Tasha: What are you doing?
Jake:拿我的哼
Jake: Take mine, huh
Tasha:你不相信我的数据线
Tasha: You don't trust my data cable?
Jake:不我就不相信你的充电宝
Jake: No, I just don't trust your power bank.
Jake:相信我的充电宝
Jake: Trust my power bank.
Lucia: 藏吧藏吧
Lucia: Hide it, hide it.
Alice:感觉我藏完明天就忘了自己藏哪了
Alice: I feel like if I hide it, I'll forget where I hid it tomorrow.
Jake:你试试
Jake: Try it.
Jake:可以可以可以
Jake: Okay, okay, okay.
Lucia:哎你放在哪里了
Lucia: Hey, where did you put it?
Jake:大对大伙藏
Jake: Hide it from everyone.
Jake:然后给我们
Jake: Then let us know.
Jake:就我们内部先知道一下
Jake: Just let our team know first.
Jake:好吧内部明天就忘了
Jake: Okay, the team will forget by tomorrow.
Lucia:估计内部明天就忘了
Lucia: The team will probably forget by tomorrow.
Jake:对对对不然自己都不记得了
Jake: Yeah, yeah, otherwise we won't even remember.
Lucia:海盗船长忘记了宝藏在哪里全剧终
Lucia: The pirate captain forgot where the treasure is, end of the story.
Jake:呵呵呵呵
Jake: Hahaha.
Shure: 看我藏那了
Shure: Look where I hid it.
Shure: 是不是不易被发现
Shure: Isn't it hard to find?
Alice:哎等一下
Alice: Hey, wait a second.
Jake:哪哪啊你藏哪了
Jake: Where, where did you hide it?
Jake:哦
Jake: Oh.
Shure: 牛吧
Shure: Impressive, right?
Jake:牛
Jake: Impressive.
Jake:挺好
Jake: Pretty good.
Alice:哎你别动
Alice: Hey, don't move.
Jake:那给我一个
Jake: Then give me one.
Jake:我也要藏
Jake: I want to hide too.
Alice:这样能藏藏
Alice: This way you can hide it.
Jake:藏人头上是吧
Jake: Hide it on the head, right?
Jake:我觉得可以藏
Jake: I think it can be hidden.
Jake:藏头里藏里
Jake: Hide it in the hair.
Jake:发卡里哈哈哈
Jake: In the hair clip, hahaha.
Shure: 我这头发能
Shure: My hair can...
Shure: 能藏藏20个是吧
Shure: Can hide 20, right?
Lucia:放书架上
Lucia: Put it on the bookshelf.
Shure: 谁给老子发消息了
Shure: Who sent me a message?
Jake:嗯这咋藏的
Jake: How did you hide it?
Lucia:了
Lucia: Done
Alice:哎呀找一个瘦一点的
Alice: Oh, find a thinner one
Shure: 你看我那就很不明显
Shure: Look, mine is not very obvious
其他人:很明显了
Others: It's very obvious
其他人:我藏了一个
Others: I hid one
Jake:你藏哪去了
Jake: Where did you hide it?
Jake:哪啊
Jake: Where?
其他人:那
Others: There
Lucia:哈
Lucia: Ha
Alice:你怎么已经发现了
Alice: How did you already find it?
Jake:哎呀不好意思不好意思
Jake: Oh, sorry, sorry
Lucia:不是你真要藏我头发
Lucia: Were you really trying to hide it in my hair?
Jake:哈哈没有没有不好意思不好意思
Jake: Haha, no, no, sorry, sorry
Jake:我以为这是个桌子
Jake: I thought it was a table
Jake:哈哈不好意思
Jake: Haha, sorry
Lucia:哈
Lucia: Ha
Jake:哈哈在在哪在哪啊在哪
Jake: Haha, where, where, where is it?
其他人:我告诉你都找不着
Others: I tell you, you won't find it
其他人:那那就完蛋了
Others: Then it's over
Jake:我靠这你确实确实
Jake: Wow, you really, really
Jake:我真以为这个桌子
Jake: I really thought it was a table
Lucia:这个位置要藏几个
Lucia: How many are you hiding in this spot?
Jake:因为原来这有个桌子
Jake: Because there used to be a table here
Lucia:这个人已经藏了一个啊
Lucia: This person has already hidden one
Lucia:那是已经藏了一个的吗
Lucia: Was one already hidden here?
其他人:藏在这个里面能看到吗
Others: Can you see it if it's hidden in here?
Lucia:好吧哎
Lucia: Okay, hey
Lucia:这不好像不是这是标签
Lucia: This doesn't seem like it, this is a label
其他人:哎呦我靠
Others: Oh my gosh
Shure: 你怎么拿出来
Shure: How did you take it out?
其他人:真看不到你怎么拿出来
Others: You really can't see it, how did you take it out?
Shure: 我想问你
Shure: I want to ask you
Alice:这是贴的
Alice: This is stuck on
Shure: 这是贴的
Shure: This is stuck on
Jake:对对对这个破坏道具了
Jake: Yeah, yeah, this broke the prop
其他人:不都全傻的吗
Others: Aren't we all just dumb?
Jake:哎不就
Jake: Oh, no, just
Alice:哈哈哈哈
Alice: Hahaha
Lucia:哈哈哈
Lucia: Hahaha
Alice:一个隐藏爆款发现结果
Alice: A hidden popular item found
其他人:我靠确实
Others: Wow, that's true.
Jake:这又是哪啊
Jake: Where is this again?
Jake:那里哈哈哈
Jake: Over there, haha.
Lucia:那里面
Lucia: Inside there.
Jake:哦这个里边
Jake: Oh, inside here.
其他人:可以直接藏厕所垃圾桶塞
Others: You could just hide it in the bathroom trash can.
Jake:哈哈你拉倒吧这怎么可能呢
Jake: Haha, no way, how is that possible?